moving on this morning in the former
Chinese president hujintao has been
unexpectedly escorted out of the ruling
Communist Party Congress the 79 year old
who is Xi jinping's immediate
predecessor appeared to be unwell but
there's been no official comment let's
speak to our Asia correspondent Helena
Smith now who's in Beijing what happened
well it was really very extraordinary
Kimberly it's hard to over exaggerate
just how very very carefully uh curated
these events are they have been
perfectly choreographed and so to have
something like this happen very very
unusual and really intriguing as well
what appeared to happen was hujintow the
former president of China the former
General Secretary of the Communist Party
one of the most important political
figures in the country he was sat just
to the side of President Xi Jinping and
then a couple of officials came over to
him they appeared to be talking to him
they appeared to be trying to persuade
him to get up and leave the room his
body language very much indicating that
he didn't want
um to go anywhere eventually they do
persuade him to get up actually one of
the officials at one point even is seen
to be almost putting his um hands under
who gentile's armpits almost trying to
sort of lift him out of the chair if you
like and then just before he leaves he
sort of leans in and Taps Xi Jinping on
the shoulder and says something and she
sort of nods and then he moved to the
side and untapped Lee kachang on the
show is the premier of China the second
in command essentially says something to
him and he also nods and then he's taken
essentially out of the hall so really
very unusual very extraordinary worth
saying that what's happening in Beijing
today is one of the most important
political events in China at the
Communist Party Congress happens once
every 20 years and essentially it's a
political event that chooses China's
next leaders and the big reveal of who
is going to be the the most senior top
team in charge of China is due to be
revealed tomorrow the timing of where
this incident fell within sort of
proceedings today is curious as well
what had been happening just before was
a session of voting to choose one of the
next senior leadership committees but
that actually happened behind the
cameras and really interestingly just
before this incident took place all the
journalist few select journalists who
are allowed into the Hall had just come
in so the whole thing was caught on a
bunch of foreign cameras and so that's
kind of intriguing within itself why
this happens well look China was an
incredibly opaque place it's hard at the
best of times to figure out exactly
what's going on and exactly why things
um happen if this was some sort of big
political power play that would be
utterly extraordinary
um it's worth saying president XI is no
change no stranger to purging his Rivals
but uh but who didn't Chow was a former
leader of the party and former leaders
are very revered another option is that
he was just potentially quite unwell
he's of advanced years he's 79 years old
he's known not to be in the best health
it's possible he was just done well and
taken out for those reasons